[Music]
it's all in your head news submitted by
Mexican hotpot a neuroscientist says
that physical pain is just in opinion
therefore you can learn to control it
all that's true though it's an opinion
everybody has one well that's
interesting you could train your pain
threshold they say happiness is a choice
what's the opposite of an opinion effect
okay right yeah so so pain is not a fact
in your body is what he's saying that
like it is it is a nerve and at his
perception so but it's not an opinion
it's more like it's definitely affected
is there so that you will not can see
like let's say you break your leg but
your perception of it your brain is
creating the people that's true okay
that's actually because that is your
brain telling you hey stop walking on
this thing because it's broken yeah but
you're gonna get worse so I for example
I let's say you go outside right it's
snowing and it's cold as [ __ ] and you're
freezing if you put room-temperature
water in a bathtub and you stick your
hand and you're anything it's bothering
you mmm you know so like your brain is
registering as 200 degrees but it's
really just 70 degrees so a lot of the
pain that you feel it is your perception
and is relative I mean these
neuroscience isn't wrong but he is
negligent like why would you even say
that to so I mean drugs make you not
feel pain sleep things are these are
these are factual the part about it
hurting it's an opinion
sure but you shouldn't ignore that
because that's how you know to get
better you know I mean yeah I don't
necessarily ignoring it is just pointing
out like people who experience chronic
pain it's pointing out that sure these
people might be experiencing pain but
it's being exacerbated because of the
way they view their pain so it's it's a
lot of it because they think it's
permanent
they think it's they can't do anything
about it but I have to take medication
to numb it versus it's probably not that
bad but then they're like like there's
some people that I know sprained an
ankle and they just work what do they
deal with did they live their life yeah
and there's other people that are also
chronic aren't dependent on these pills
I have to take them to get what everyone
experiences pain at different like
they're cold yeah yeah it's a spectrum
yeah right so like for example they
write in this article he
anyone who has willed themselves to not
feel a tickle as ticklish can appreciate
the difference between stimulation
possible and our perception of it
I know people who are ticklish when I
get tickled that's it that's impossible
can't undo it I used to be like that too
but then now when I get tickled like not
to the extreme I'm not saying like I'm
[ __ ] the tickle master but I can will
it enough to like fight off its tickle
ends opinion - he's like me and Isaac we
had a lot of training together I think
it is cute as game my son Oh cute ass
gamer she was like a toddler now he's
about to turn 12 but when I was like
three ish I remember we used to be in
his car seat and we still play this game
where he'd have his hands up and I would
tickle him and then like we have I would
count how long he would last before he
puts his arms down five and then he put
his arms out oh I don't think I want to
lose it
I want that the ability to just laugh
like a [ __ ] lunatic yeah if somebody
squeezes my knees - ha ha - you know
like see you haven't already just a
thought of like if my dad would just be
driving and I always said that a red
light he which is just dig right into my
knees cute grabby in my inner thighs and
you would say in Spanish you'd say wow
your jeans are so thick look how thick
your jeans are that's just a childhood
memory I wanna you know that's true
another one is like discomfort and
swelling increase when people believe a
pain believed a painful hand or knee is
larger and then it decreases when it
seems smaller oh yeah yeah yeah and then
they're saying that injections are less
painful when we don't watch that oh yeah
that's true yeah cuz uh you can try the
difference of watching like if you're
getting your blood drawn
I love one or just look away and just
start talking when you look away and
just start talking it's almost like well
for me it's almost like it's not even
there but when I'm looking at it then it
starts to hurt the longer it's in there
do you have little things
don't bother me yeah what about me
Oh like the people would draw your blood
are called phlebotomist oh so then um
yeah like I thought because of that
reason I like staring at it but it
actually does feel like more painful
when I pour pressure you can fill it or
the longer this syringe dad gets a
little like Danny you got to put that in
me like going out
so when medicines going I'm like I'm
gonna get better yeah then when they're
doing blood samples and are taking vows
after vial I'm just like what am I gonna
have laughing you're taking a lot of
blood yeah when I donate blood I just
wanna feel like I went up passed out cuz
you I see you on the movies like oh yeah
so like couldn't someone does like
taking the blood and I see the back
filling up I always go yes
am I gonna black out and then they're
done I'm like I feel like I want to be
like I want to be in this space like
Inception really cool [ __ ] never gets
there so then another thing they say in
this article is when our brains decide
to interpret a sensation as painful it
also sends a signal back to the body
that intensifies that feeling so nerve
endings can chemically change in
response to signals from the brain pain
is more like a conversation between the
brain and the body and like verbal
conversations it can be heated or calm
so like if you're afraid it can make
your pain worse cuz you're tense in the
same way that stress I remember one my
philosophy teacher I think Emory was or
psychiatrist he said that the number one
killer of people is stress but you'll
never see that on anyone's death
certificate you'll see like something
else because stress right makes it more
extravagant look whatever you're feeling
at a time yeah I wonder if you can
mentally like people were into pain I'm
at a play
from pain in person you said with
Shaolin monks lead oh this was a dream
themselves no not to kick each other in
the nuts yeah we're like you know smack
them on the Adhan like that's part of
their exercises like hey you should
stand there give me a stick mm yeah and
then they just don't like the Sith and
Darth is doing the explaining it or okay
pain is pleasure for some people yeah I
could tap into the penis pleasure
mentality because yeah I mean I like
Geng Chun I like getting like yours
pierced and [ __ ] like piercings like
there was a time in my life when I was a
team that I just wanted to like just
[ __ ] pierce my nipples pierced it
abuts like what if you go like on a hike
and your lungs are burning you like oh
that feels so good I'm running out of
air death is eternal for some people
that's painful that's David Kerri I
could find some payment because
exercising is a lot of painful it's
that's my pleasure though like feeling
some a little bit of pain through
certain things like now I'm doing this
thing called that cold therapy and I
hated the cold and I always told myself
that I'm not a cold person I like I'm a
warm person I like tropical so I've like
why do I hate it so much it's just
weather like there's nothing to really
hate and some people love it how come I
can't teach myself to love it so I
started going to the waterfall and
seeing how long I can stay in there is
it cold
it's ice-cold man cuz all the snow is
melting right now I've heard of people
freezing to death and not like I don't
know being hot today II didn't realize
it was opinion ya know it's crazy change
you're my brother
there's guys out there that are doing
like ice bath therapy and all this [ __ ]
yes they're beating what people thought
was possible in science so they'll be
like oh you'll go in this water
I'll take you about three minutes to get
hypothermia or something like that and
they'll be going in for like 10 minutes
this is guy named wim hof he broke all
these records and he he kind of like
defied the history I mean at the
textbooks of like what humans are
capable of doing in cold she went and
climb Mount Everest like in just boxer
shorts Oh were the people who did the
cross-country skiing they like in Canada
they went across like some sort of like
Basin I've just Frost with tights on or
whatever just doing that [ __ ] yeah
man it's crazy what the mind can do yeah
yeah and and his whole thing is like the
mind can actually beat a lot of stuff so
adding more to his whole pain perception
thing they're saying that pain can be
lessened when we feel safe so there was
this study back in 1956 and in it they
had wounded World War two soldiers
compared to civilians with similar
injuries and they said that 83% of the
civilians requested narcotic painkillers
only 32% of the soldiers did because
once they went home they felt a sense
they felt that sense of safety
diminished or feeling of pain mm-hmm so
even being safe yeah and probably they
were like been through crazy-ass
hardship so they're like having a call
that homes not a big deal versus my
eardrums being blown out because of
constant mortars and stuff
I believe in exposure to discomfort and
shock in small doses because the
perception of pain it depends on your
baseline so like let's say if you're
used to being warm and cozy then if you
don't have a jacket on that's painful
yeah I'll [ __ ] you up
right but then instead of a jacket maybe
you wear a long sleeve or like a thinner
shirt right like like a thinner jacket
and then you you you get used to that
and then you you can get to a t-shirt
you might be able to get to shirtless at
some point and then be like it's not
that bad so if you do a baby step
exposure to things it's almost like if
you run a marathon overnight that's
gonna give you a lot of pain but if
do like five miles and then ten miles
and then whatever that's also alignments
yeah you build it up like I was doing
that to my feet like for a couple of
years because I had baby feet so then I
would go walk outside barefoot you had
baby she like on you attached to you
really sensitive feet yeah and you just
you just got rid of the toes
yeah so I could walk outside barefoot
and it's not that I didn't lose feeling
the pain just it doesn't hurt I can
still feel you know like the floor
that's what David brain building the
resilience and not necessarily your
actual could be the brain that lose the
street magician David Blaine Blaine yeah
he does he does that yeah he does all
types of resistance to pain trainer
yeah like breath holding breath holding
has taking her pipe through your oh my
god
[Music]
[Music]